le plus haut des vols de voiture ne
faiblit pas 53 véhicules volés ont été
retrouvés hier dans le port de Montréal
ça pose des véhicules de luxe des vies
des camionnettes plein de grandeur de
type P4 valeur un peu plus de 2 millions
et demi de dollars tous destinés être
vendus à l'étranger et principalement
dans les pays en voie de développement
depuis le début de l'année 252 véhicules
volés ont été saisis au port de Montréal
de ce nombre 22 à 23% ont été volés au
Québec dont la moitié à Montréal tout le
reste provenait de l'Ontario sur le
territoire on parle d'une tendance à peu
près 800 véhicules volés par mois un
phénomène qui est en hausse dans la
métropole depuis les cinq dernières
années alors que le nombre de véhicules
volés a plus que doublé c'est une
question d'offres de demande
dans certains pays la demande pour
certains véhicules est en forte hausse
et des groupes criminalisés du Canada
s'organisent pour répondre à cette
demande au port de Montréal plus de 2000
conteneurs arrivent chaque jour avec des
marchandises c'est véhicules pénètre au
port de Montréal d'abord et avant tout
dans des conteneurs salés exactement
comme les marchandises qui ont tout à
fait et qui sont lisses et qui font
partie d'un commerce tout à fait
légitime notre rôle est limité par à la
fois la loi sur les douanes qui
empêchent les ports de Montréal de
ouvrir des cellules procéder elle-même
par exemple à des inspections ce rôle
est entièrement dévolué aux douanes dans
cette compagnie de système de repérage
de véhicule volés une hausse des cas
aussi était remarquée les gens ont
beaucoup d'options la meilleure façon
c'est de parler avec leur compagnie
d'assurance au Québec on est en aval du
reste du Canada vis-à-vis des programmes
de gestion de risques vis-à-vis le vol
auto les véhicules volés sont
généralement vendus deux à trois fois
plus cher ou 3 mers ici Daniel ca djo
Radio-Canada Montréal